finland has officially declared that it
will apply for nato membership finnish
president sauli ninisto and prime
minister suleiman made the announcement
in a joint press conference in helsinki
finland shares a long border with russia
the finnish parliament is expected to
endorse the decision in the coming days
nato secretary general jens stoltenberg
welcomed the statement during a meeting
of nato foreign ministers in berlin he
also expressed hope that ukraine could
win the war against russia
if they decided to fly
this would be an historic moment
their membership in nato would increase
our shared security
demonstrate that nato's door is open
and that aggression
does not pay
while stoltenberg's sentiment was echoed
by germany's foreign minister analina
bairbach who also reiterated germany's
support for ukraine
we agree that we must not and will not
let up in our national efforts
especially in terms of military support
for as long as ukraine needs this
support for the self-defense of its
country
let's get more now from our brussels
bureau chief alexander von nerman who is
in berlin following the foreign
minister's meeting for us what were the
other main takeaways from this nato
press conference
i would say there were three main
takeaways from this press conference
first of all the fact that the german
foreign minister as well as nato
secretary general stoltenberg were quite
confident that the whole process
after finland and sweden will formally
apply for nato membership that the whole
process will be very swift despite
turkey's misgivings about sweden and
finland joining the alliance and it was
also very interesting to hear from
stoltenberg that uh the even though uh
the process the process still needs to
be completed uh um now the alliance is
already ready to beef up its presence in
the black in the i'm sorry in the
in the region in the northern region and
they that are ready to offer some
security assurances to finland in sweden
in this very difficult transition time
in which both country are not yet
formally covered but by the article
of the alliance that is saying that an
attack on one of them would be
considered an attack of on all of them
and the last takeaway i would say was
also very interesting that stoltenberg
as well as the us secretary of state
blink
said that they believe that ukraine can
win this war and that russia's brutal
aggression lost momentum there
now finland's president did say that
there's been some mixed signals coming
from turkey about his country's
application to nato let's listen to what
he had to say
you can understand that i'm a bit
confused
what we heard
two days ago was different then
yesterday
we again heard that
turkey is open to our membership but
it turned back to no i i think that
what we need now is a very clear answer
prepared to have a new discussion with
president erdogan about
the problems he has raised
so alexandra what's currently being done
to dial down the tensions with turkey to
reach an agreement
well first of all finland and sweden
wants to talk to turkey wants to keep
the dialogue hoping to resolve for the
issue we know that the most important
point for turkey here is to convince
both countries to lift their arms
delivery restrictions on turkey the
second thing that i think is also very
interesting that instead of talking many
here um have made clear that they think
that eventually turkey
is not going to undermine
the unity of nato that it's now so
important in phase of russia's war on
ukraine
and how much would finland joining nato
change nato
well finland we have to say
is a very close partner of nato
finland has a very resilient very strong
democratic society this is
one of the most important criteria here
finland has also a high capable army
that is already part of a nato military
structure so it would benefit the
alliance of course and as we heard here
today be also very good for finland to
become a member of the alliance
ttw's alexandra von naman thank you very
much
ukraine says the front lines in the east
of the country are shifting russia has
made some gains in the donbass region
but ukraine says it's waging a
counter-offensive on the russian health
city of izum
kiev says russian forces retreated from
ukraine's second city kharkiv to shore
up its defensives of izum ukrainian
forces have been clearing the liberated
villages near kharkiv and residents
there have now started refocusing on
rebuilding their lives
you